aujourd'hui nous montons à la butte
montmartre expression consacrée par
l'habitant de la capitale mais aussi
expression logique puisque par rapport
aux autres quartiers de paris le
sacré-coeur juché sur la colline abrite
sur ses flancs tous ceux qui aiment
montmartre de tous côtés sépare des rues
escarpées et d escalier raide que l'on y
accède tout semble prétexte au jeu des
jeunes de ce village parisien
même les vitres des lampadaires ont été
remplacés par des grilles les tireurs à
la fronde finissait par être trop habile
surtout à la sortie de l'école des
garçons de la rue du mont-cenis 6 juste
au milieu d'escalier propre à ce
quartier comme à toutes les sorties
d'école les gars ont libéré s'échappe en
chahutant et en se bousculant dominique
lui est pressé en vrai gosse de la butte
il est au courant de ce qui se passe
dans son village un bateau à côté de
l'église saint pierre ne l'étonnent pas
montmartre est en fait on célèbre son
sixième centenaire et ce beau bateau
sera vendue aux enchères tout le profit
de cette vente sera au bénéfice des
enfants de la butte sur la place du
tertre où dominique aime à flâner en
vrai bad au parisien le spectacle qu'il
y ait fait ou pas et permanent quelle
que soit la saison
la petite place typiquement provincial
et le royaume d'une société de peintre à
qui la solitude n'est pas indispensable
bien au contraire et pour qui les sujets
d'inspiration s'il s'était pur au départ
se sont transformés suivant le goût
quelquefois douteux du client il ya bien
sûr des exceptions
les peintres sont les amis de dominique
et puis ils sont très forts il parle
toutes les langues ou du moins ils
savent proposer à touristes étrangers de
lui faire son portrait en anglais en
espagnol en allemand en italien et en
russe
ici les artistes peignent font leurs
comptes
sous l'oeil de la centenaire de
montmartre et les touristes regardent
photographie h est quelquefois
pour